[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
this guy has attention to detail see
what I did with that bloop bloop Darren
Revell Action Network business reporter
memorabilia collector and he joins us on
the program just saw where ESPN is
saying Michael Jordan selling the team
the Charlotte Hornets
what uh what do you think Mike's going
to walk away why do you think he's
selling
just a great time right when he first
bought the Hornet stand
um
he I think he put down uh like less than
10 percent because he was my uncle
Jordan which is what he should have done
I mean that's what that's what you do
um and uh and then over time he got to
80 90
and uh then he sold off to to give
Plotkin a little bit of it and Gabe's
one of the guys who's buying it today uh
an unbelievable job in terms of like
there's been things that Michael Jordan
where he's made some mistakes probably
that he didn't get an actual piece of
Nike might be his biggest mistake right
like instead of getting just royalties
he did pretty well though Darren
yeah he made more than a billion dollars
on Nike but still but still you always
got to try to uh is this perpetuity for
Michael after Michael passes away where
his kid's grandkids he's got a lot yeah
absolutely yeah he's he's making money
on the Air Jordan brand forever okay um
but with this Hornets thing and maybe
you'll disagree with me here I don't
think his legacy is tarnished by the
fact that the Hornet stunk throughout
his tenure
um
I I think because there's such a
disparity between being the greatest
basketball player of all time I always
tell people just because you're a great
player doesn't mean you're a great
manager or coach or in this case a great
great owner and sometimes you you he
could control what he did on the floor
he can't control this he can't make the
Charlotte Hornets better by just willing
them it's got to be decisions that he's
made and he's made some of the worst
draft picks in recent basketball history
Darren
yeah and I I would I would say his time
with the Washington Wizards stand
probably tarnished his legacy more than
anything that he did as a hornet's owner
so again I you know I I think the fact
that he's going to come away with
uh we're talking probably total 850 to
900 million dollars net here
um I think it's a it's a good move and
didn't really kill him too much as far
as his name goes is Jordan a memorabilia
business on to himself
for sure
um although obviously there's
intricacies on what's big what's not you
know his 1986 Fleer rookie card in a PSA
10 so that's the highest graded there's
323 of those
um and they're now about 180 000 a piece
during the pandemic it went as high as
786 000.
um you know but there are what pieces
are you buying and I think I always say
when there's real one-off pieces when
they're when it's one of one that's
really where you're in good shape and
you know these these Flu Game shoes that
just sold again for the second time so
they first sold in 2013 straight from
the ball boy uh Preston Truman for a
hundred five thousand dollars and then
they just sold for 1.38 million and I
think the reason for that over times
this is not just inflation is you know
you just look at there it's one of one
it's Jordan's most iconic game and to
own a piece of that that's authenticated
that's real
um I think the game use stuff the good
game use stuff particularly for the past
when they didn't wear four to five
jerseys and eight to ten shoes but is
anybody anybody close to Jordan in in
any other sport
uh
I mean Gretzky's Jersey from his last
um you know game with the Rangers is
less NHL game just sold for about 750
000. I think Jordan's kind of on his own
although like you know I collect tickets
and the the bigger ticket than Jordan's
debut is Jackie Robinson's debut there's
fewer of them obviously it's from 1947
but as a whole I think do you have one
of those Darren Jackie Robinson debut
tickets
I do not uh I had a chance to buy one
um
I had to take I would have had to take
it off the back of something and I was
worried about uh the the wear and tear
on it I probably shouldn't have that was
a mistake but I do not have one of those
I do have uh uh I do have Bobby Orr's
flying goal ticket uh there's only four
of them 1970.
um is is Jordan memorabilia a good
investment
or is it buying too high I think it just
depends I just think it depends on on
what it is right like so you know at the
high end that 86 Jordan flear like I
mean that that went down I think it
depends on what you're buying each you
can't just say there's a there was a
tweet recently that I put out where
Patrick Mahomes one of his greatest
cards has declined since he won the the
two Super Bowls and I think it's just
based on it's not just a factor we're
not just playing fantasy out here right
there's a lot of factors behind this how
many were made how many were kept what
what's the condition of them and I think
you know you just have to I I like one
of ones I also like to go contrarian Dan
so like I brought you
okay eight uncirculated uncut dollar
bills signed by Warren Buffett you know
think that way okay you know now you
have LeBron James debut game tickets dub
signed by his mother
so that that that that's what that
that's what actually sold last night uh
I bid on it
um I actually like that's just how you
think in a contrarian way Dan right like
signed by his mother when are you gonna
ever get his mother you can get LeBron
but not his mother and and and from a
storytelling standpoint his mother is a
single mother and them going to three or
four or five different places when he's
growing up part of his story and
remarkably right LeBron James lived up
to the hype so I always like the the
story you can tell let me show you one
and that sold for five thousand dollars
yesterday yeah I mean that's a good
that's I for me I think that's a good
value let me show you what else do you
have here um so it was recently the 50th
anniversary of Secretariat winning the
Belmont uh so this is signed by this is
the program
okay program is not rare not rare this
is signed by Ron turcotte the jockey of
course but it's also signed by secretary
oh no secretary no
and there's a hoof print right here yeah
um it's also signed by Penny Tweety now
what's interesting about this is that
Penny Chenery is the name that people
know her by right that's her maiden name
she was married to Jack Tweedy while she
was uh while she was the owner
Secretariat and they got divorced five
months later so what is this prove this
shows that this was signed
contemporaneously during the so this was
signed before February 74. so like you
know you think about these type of
things and I also think about when
things look
really cool like when you show it to
someone they say wow that's amazing I
think the greatest ticket ever made was
Allen Iverson's debut and it was
actually Allen Iverson and Ray Allen in
the same game both their abused the
reason why the ticket was incredible was
because it was the opening of the core
States Center so it was just the first
game in the core state center it wasn't
because it was their debut just happens
to be and this is the ticket you can see
how big it is oh wow and what's cool is
you could see like you could see that
rookie Allen right there I mean you can
see three Jerry stack houses and uh
Clarence Weatherspoon too and a Derek
Coleman but but but but still like these
are the cool things like so when I tell
people what when people say what should
I collect I always say collect something
that will make people say wow
we're talking to Darren Revell Action
Network business reporter I remember
being in Craig Sager's Bar in Atlanta
Seger had
some
uh
no no he had George Brett's jockstrap
he had morgana's bra
Annie that's a good play and he had some
uh
calpy's from Secretariat he had some
he had some poop from Secretariat and he
had it in a display window at his sports
bar jocks and Jill's I don't you don't
you don't forget that if it was just a
Michael Jordan rookie you know you might
have forgotten it but those are three
items that oh
what's our Ryan Leaf jersey worth the
Colts jersey with Ryan's autograph on it
oh that's a good one I like that the the
draft pick that didn't happen I didn't
even know you had that yeah yeah he wore
it or promo shoot and then
um he ended up giving it to us and so he
signed his Colts jersey that he would
have gotten at if they had not taken it
I think I think that's I think that's
worth a solid
eight thousand dollars wait are you
making me an offer
no well maybe after
no I need more than that no you know
what I got so much stuff in here I don't
even know what's valuable what's your oh
let me ask you this what's your greatest
piece and what is your greatest regret
of not taking something that someone
offered to you
foreign
I saved everything
I but I don't I did I never collected to
collect I collected because I I just
loved it
um but I I don't have any regrets where
I go God I should have because it's
interesting now that game used stuff is
going crazy because so so at the end of
the month Michael Jordan's dream team
jacket the famous one that had the
Reebok logo on it that he covered is up
for sale I think it's a five to eight
million dollar jacket that was given to
Brian McKnight remember hold on yeah I
know Brian worked at the NBA a long time
five to eight million
yes oh boy
I asked Brian recently I go where was
that he's like oh did you see my closet
with all the other uh you know stuff but
but who would know right and and it's
it's just come upon us where there was a
Jordan jersey that sold for 10 million
and Brian saw that and you know but
Jordan just throw it to him but you know
Darren every time I did the Bulls
winning the championship I saw a
transaction happen right in front of me
every time Michael when he won a title
and he came in to sit with me on
SportsCenter
he took his shoes off and handed them to
the Chicago Bulls PR director
Tim Hallam yeah
right in front of me I saw that
transaction where Mike autographed him
and gave them to Tim
and Tim is actually auctioning them I
think it's Tim because there's there are
signed uh Jordans from every
Championship uh that are that's also up
in southern yeah I saw it so I don't
know it's Tim but I think it is Tim yeah
saw it right in front of me uh I saw it
I saw where you bought uh Ferris
Bueller's vest from Ferris Bueller's Day
Off
if I did the only one worn by Matthew
Broderick how much how much did it cost
155 000.
can you let me tell you socially
no I will never put it on my body that
would be very disrespectful okay all
right but okay but I will tell you the
philosophy behind this is as game use
stuff is going crazy if LeBron's game
seven jersey from the 2013 NBA finals
goes for 3.7 million
what is ferris's vest I don't know
ferris's best see I would love to have
Indiana Jones's fedora
yeah that actually there was actually
one that sold I don't know if it's one
of one but it's hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of dollars
yeah I'd love to happen yeah
what's your wife say when you go honey
look what I bought
I don't tell her
[Laughter]
luckily she doesn't watch The Dan
Patrick well she's in the minority there
because everybody including everybody in
Denver loves this show hey great to talk
to you as always uh thanks for the uh
the insight you gotta take care of Dan
Darren Revell Action Network business
reporter